growing up we all have impressions of
the middle ages we read about knights in
shining armor hassles with moats and
towers but when were the middle ages
the simple answer the middle ages in
europe are the roughly 1 000 years from
the fall of the roman empire and to be
particular the fall of the western roman
empire the eastern roman empire
continues on for most of the middle ages
but it starts in roughly 476 and it
continues on for a thousand years as we
get into the 14th and 15th centuries and
it's really the time period that
connects the world of rome europe during
antiquity and connects it to the europe
that begins to emerge in the 14th 15th
and 16th centuries the europe of the age
of exploration the europe of the
renaissance now what we're going to do
in this video is we're going to look at
maps of the various time periods of the
middle ages the middle ages are broadly
divided into three major sections the
early middle ages from the fall of the
western roman empire till about the year
1000 the high middle ages which was a
high point for the middle ages in europe
which goes from about what the year 1000
to the year 1300 and then the late
middle ages which gets us to the 15th
century and is considered not that
pleasant of a time to live in europe
so let's just start with what europe
looked like right after the fall of the
western roman empire
so as you can see here this map is
referring to the time period between 476
when otto acre or otoasser takes over
rome and 493 and you can see the eastern
roman empire is still here but the
western roman empire is now fragmented
amongst many germanic kingdoms you have
the visigoths you have the franks you
have the kingdom of odo aker or odo acer
with the fall of rome we are entering
into the early middle ages now the
eastern roman empire which considers
itself the roman empire it's its capital
at constantinople under justinian has a
little bit of a last hurrah and is able
to recapture the italian peninsula so
it's able to recapture some of the
territory that was formerly part of the
western roman empire some of the
territory in north africa that you don't
see on this map
but for the most part western europe
stays under the control of various
germanic kingdoms
so here we have fast forwarded to the
year
814 which would be right around
here on our timeline
and you can see a major event has
occurred either on the map or on this
timeline you have charlemagne king of
the franks crowned holy roman emperor on
the map you can see charlemagne's empire
right over here he has conquered
northern italy much of what we consider
modern day france much of what we
consider modern day germany switzerland
near the netherlands and belgium
charlemagne is really one of the
defining figures of the middle ages and
especially the early middle ages as you
can see he's able to unify
much of western europe a lot of our our
ideas about kings and castles and nights
began to emerge around the time of
charlemagne
this notion of being a holy roman
emperor because he's able to provide
protection to the pope the pope says hey
i'm going to say that you are continuing
on the legacy of the roman empire now as
we'll see and we cover in much more
detail in other videos the holy the
title holy roman emperor or emperor of
the romans does not continue on with
charlemagne's descendants but when you
get to 962
otto who's a german king is crowned holy
roman emperor again and you continue to
have holy roman emperors all the way
until 1806.
now another major feature of the early
middle ages and you can see it on this
map is that islam in the 7th and 8th
centuries it comes out of arabia and is
able to conquer much of the middle east
persia north africa which you don't see
on this map and much of what we consider
today to be modern day spain and you can
see it you see the caliphate or of
cordoba right over here you see the
abbasids here in the east who also
controlled much of north africa
now let's fast forward to the high
middle ages
so here we are in the year 1135
on our timeline that would be right
about let's see this is 1100 that would
be 11 50 11
would put us right around here and you
could already see some interesting
things on this map
the holy roman empire under charlemagne
is now fragmented the western third is
now the kingdom of france the eastern
two thirds are still considered the
roman germanic empire or the holy roman
empire
and even though it looks fairly unified
in this map over different periods of
time it's really a bunch of fragmented
germanic kingdoms nominally under this
holy roman empire sometimes it's a
little bit more unified under a stronger
holy roman
emperor now the other things that you
see and we saw it on the last map is
that the byzantine empire is continuing
to lose territory and you can see the
muslim empires in this case it's the
seljuk turks are able to take even more
territory now one of the things that has
happened by the time we look at this map
and it's not clear by looking on the map
is that you have in 1054 the great
schism between the latin church centered
at rome and the eastern greeks church
centered at constantinople and we have a
whole series of videos on that and all
of the factors that led to it
but as we get to the time of this map
one of the things that the high middle
ages is most known for the great schism
or the east west schism is one of them
the schism between what eventually
becomes the roman catholic church and
the eastern orthodox church but what the
high middle ages are also known for are
the crusades
as already mentioned you see how the
seljuk turks are able to take much of
anatolia much of the peninsula from the
byzantine empire and the west decides to
send what will eventually be called
crusaders to help regain land from the
muslims and so that's where you see the
crusades beginning in 1096 at the very
end of the 11th century you can see the
multiple crusades that occur over
roughly the next 200 years
and the crusaders were trying to reclaim
land from the muslims and especially the
holy land much of which is below the map
where you can't quite see it right over
here but it turns out that when they are
able to reclaim some of that land they
don't give it back to the byzantines
they set up what are known as crusader
kingdoms and you can see some of them
right over here in this bluish color so
once again you had this east west schism
and the crusades are further expanding
the division between east and west and
that really becomes significant in 1204
when the crusaders themselves sack
constantinople take constantinople from
the byzantines so that's in some ways
the point of no return the byzantines
are eventually able to take
constantinople back but this is really
the beginning of the end for the
byzantine empire
now even though the high middle ages are
known for this tension between east and
west the great schism even though it's
known for the crusades most of which
were fairly unsuccessful despite being
very very very bloody for the crusaders
the high middle ages were considered a
high point for the middle ages farming
technology coupled with better weather
actually significantly increased
agricultural productivity at this time
but then roughly in the year 1300
historians consider ourselves moving
into the late middle
ages so you can see here in this map by
the late middle ages
europe is starting to resemble the
europe that we know in later periods
once we get into the renaissance and the
age of exploration
by this point
much of the iberian peninsula has been
reclaimed from muslim rule although you
still have muslim rule in granada
most of the byzantine empire has now
been taken over by the ottomans save
constantinople constantinople eventually
falls in 1453.
this map right over here is roughly what
europe looked like in the 14th century
so
this period right over here
constantinople falls in 1453 ending the
byzantine empire formally
and what the late middle ages is most
known for as being not that pleasant of
a time to live in europe in 1347
you have the black death which by some
estimates kills 50 million people in
europe which is roughly 60 percent of
the population at the time it's also a
time of famine the weather cycles get
worse and even before the black death
you have a significant famine occurring
in the 14th century
you can see right over here between 1337
and 1453
you have the hundred years war between
france and england which lasts over a
hundred years once again not a pleasant
time to live in especially western
europe but as we get into the end of the
15th and especially into the 16th
century historians consider that to be
the end of the middle ages and we start
getting into the age of exploration and
the renaissance which we will discuss in
future videos